>>> I want you to take a look at
this.
The U.S. Navy release new images
of the Chinese spy balloon they
recovered in the waters off of
South Carolina.
This is really intriguing to
see, Chinese balloon shot down
over the weekend.
>> Right now, the house
committee is holding a hearing
to look at the failures of the
government not detecting Chinese
incursions in the trump
administration.
What are you learning, Oren
Liebermann?
>> I was watching house
committee, and although it was
scheduled before the latest
Chinese government has been
discovered, it has been a topic
of the committee, and the
chairman said that you would
have to be naive to know that it
was not an attempt by China to
spy on the United States.
Last year, there was a report
called the people's republic of
China high altitude means.
It documents case in 2019 where
a balloon flew all around the
world over Hawaii and over
flying parts of southern Florida
in the trump administration, and
what is unclear in this report
is when the U.S. Realized it was
a Chinese surveillance balloon,
and the Pentagon believed that
is the intent of the balloon,
and this is another point that
the Pentagon said yesterday,
general Glenn vanerk said that
there was an awareness gap that
allowed China to fly balloons
three times over the U.S. In the
trump administration without
them knowing it, and it was only
later that the U.S. Went back to
look at the data and the
trajectories of these balloons
that they came to believe they
were surveillance balloon, and
the gap is what the U.S. Is
trying the close now especially
now that it has the balloon in
hand or parts of it as we see
with the images, and working to
recover the rest of it, Kate.
>> Oren, thank you so much.
>>> The FBI lab as we have been
seeing the images and what is
being recovered, the FBI is
identifying the parts of the
downed balloon.
Carlos, what is the latest from
there?
>> Kate, so we are about 21
miles off of the main debris
zone off of the coast of south
Carolina, and it is quite clear
that the FBI and the Navy are
starting to make preparations to
bring the debris here.
It is a boat ramp and parking
lot to the north of where the
search is taking place and where
for the past three days the Navy
has prepositioned a lot of the
equipment, and a lot of the
personnel.
It is where we saw a number of
boats being brought in this
morning and heavy equipment and
oxygen tanks.
An FBI agent told us earlier
that they were securing the
event in the event that they
might have to bring some of the
debris out here, and in the last
few minutes, we saw flood lights
and a forklift and storage
containers.
In the main debris site off of
the coast of South Carolina
which is a half hour's drive
here, the crews have been using
the equipment to essentially
scan the bottom of the ocean
there to get a sense of how much
of this debris is still left
there.
Once they get that done, then
they will start the work of
lifting the debris out to ship,
and most likely bring it out
here or to Virginia.
>> Thank you, Carlos.
And joining us is James clapper,
the former director of national
intelligence under president
Obama.
And now I want to put up these
images of the U.S. Navy, and I
believe they are fascinating of
what is being pulled in, and a
much closer look at what they
are recovering from the Chinese
spy balloon, and we will put
them up when we get them, but
what are you seeing here?
>> It looks to me as part of the
larger deringer and the suite
carried by the balloon, itself,
and this is a good sign, because
it would indicate hopefully
where this was going on, it is
in relatively close proximity to
the payload which is the key
thing that you want to get here
to analyze just what was the
center suite, and what were the
Chinese actually trying to do,
and what were they are trying to
collect with this balloon.
>> Absolutely right.
And to another big question that
is being reported by Oren
Liebermann, and the previous
incursions and what the U.S.
Commander is saying about the
previous incursions by Chinese
balloons is that they went
undetected and what he said is a
domain awareness gap.
What does that mean to you?
>> Well, that is a military
jargon for we missed it.
There is gray nether world for
which the conventional military
craft fly 40,000 feet and below
and then we have good coverage.
We can detect aircraft and other
vehicles in that regime 40,000
feet and below.
With respect to spacecraft, we
do a great job of tracking them,
and there not a color, but there
is an area where we don't
apparently have a good technical
capability of tracking objects
in that zone of altitude if you
will, and so that is what is
afoot here.
I am sure that we can bring to
bear the resources to overtime
correct this deficiency, this
domain awareness gap to use the
phrase.
>> Yeah, I will try to work that
into conversation more.
And so, you said that the
balloon had gone off course, and
can you tell me more about that,
and when you say that, do you
believe it is not a spy balloon?
>> No, no.
I did not mean to imply that at
all, Kate.
What I meant is that I believe
that the Chinese may have been
truthful of it wandering off
course, but I don't think they
have been truthful of the center
suite on it.
I think that it is clearly for
intelligence collection
purposes.
I have had some experience of my
time with the intelligence
communities with intelligence
collection balloons, and you are
subject to the vagaries of
weather, the fog, mist and rain
and in this case most critically
wind.
That is by the way, one of the
interesting things that we can
learn is just how much control